[Music]
in 1703 an anonymous Englishman known to
history only as mr. C wrote to the Royal
Society of London to report on a
peculiar observation he'd made using
only a simple microscope he'd been
looking at the roots of pond weed but as
he looked closer he found attached to
the roots quote many pretty branches
composed of rectangular oblongs and
exact squares at first he assumed that
these geometric attachments must be salt
crystals but the more he experimented
and looked through his microscope the
more he realized there might be
something amazing going on here these
tiny beautiful shapes seemed kind of
plant-like today with the benefit of
many many more observations and far
superior equipment we know that this
18th century letter is one of the
earliest descriptions of a diatom a
photosynthetic unicellular algae that
could become so plentiful that oceanic
blooms of these organisms which we
cannot see individually without a
microscope are nonetheless visible from
a space
[Music]
but we wouldn't be talking about diatoms
if we needed to be in space to observe
them you can find these tiny organisms
just about anywhere that has water and
light looking at them through a
microscope you might understand why
microbe hunters are so fond of them they
have been called the jewels of the sea
those beautiful outer shells are called
fresh jewels and they set diatoms apart
from every other living creature unlike
the organic cell walls and membranes we
associate with most sells fresh jewels
are made out of inorganic silica
enclosing the cytoplasm of the diatom in
what is basically glass silica shells
take less energy to make and maintain
compared to their organic counterparts
but they do come with a trade-off glass
is well it's glass it's hard to expand
if you're a unicellular organism trying
to undergo asexual mitosis when your
cell is enclosed in a rigid inorganic
material instead when diatoms divide the
daughter cells take the old fresh jewel
and divide it between them which means
that the daughter cells are both going
to be smaller than their parent and they
are never going to grow any bigger
and as diatoms keep dividing the
daughter cells keep getting smaller and
smaller if this goes on forever the
diatom will get so small that it cannot
survive
but diatoms that are starting to get too
small can avoid that fate through sexual
reproduction which is a kind of refresh
button that lets them construct
a new fresh tool for a larger daughter
cell for the most part diatoms can't
actually move they just go wherever the
water takes them but some diatoms are
able to glide along a surface using a
slit in their fresh tool called a reef
this allows them to secrete mucus that
sticks to a surface but how does that
mucus help them move we don't know we
can see that they move so they must be
able to and we can see that mucus is
always left behind when they do it but
we don't know the exact mechanism of how
it works
you and I of course move using muscles
and the molecules responsible for that
in us are actin and myosin here's a wild
thing in 1999 some scientists put actin
disrupting compounds in solution with
diatoms and those diatoms lost their
ability to move so while diatom motility
remains something of a mystery these
tiny jewel-encrusted algae move using
the same molecular systems as us
if you've been looking closely you might
be wondering what these bubbles are and
if you are we hope we can surprise you
those are oil droplets and they store
energy for the diatom when they might be
having trouble finding light or their
usual nutrients these little organisms
are so good at creating this fatty oil
that scientists have wondered whether we
might use diatoms as tiny factories that
turn sunlight and carbon dioxide into
fuel not just for them but for our
future airplanes it might be tempting to
think of these cells just as little
microscopic jewels just something nice
to look at but they also have a huge
impact on our world of all of the
photosynthesis being done on earth
around one-fifth is done by diatoms
which puts them on par with all rain
forests on earth combined and it means
that we owe a great deal to these mega
organisms and not just our oxygen when
they die
there's silica fresh jewels sink to the
bottom of the water that they're in and
accumulate into a soft chalky Rock that
we know better as diatomaceous earth
that key ingredient in beer and wine
filtration paint and of course cat
litter so yes these beautiful jewels
that the unknown mr. C spotted in 1703
don't just provide us with every fifth
breath we take they also help make our
cat litter more absorbent and also
they're just really nice to look at
so thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us if you want to see
more from our master of microscopes
James check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby